okay i got a random question i i was
like really thought about securi
genuinely curious if you've ever
apologized for a joke
yeah yeah yeah but i do it to an the
individual that i heard if i was if
listen if i'm in a bad mood
okay now some asshole's going to cut
that right there so you communion should
apologize because that's everybody's
like fox news and cnn now like
staring at it
they'll cut out all this [ __ ] no if i'm
in like a bad mood
and like
or if i did if i told a joke about
something that somebody had a personal
effect to it and i made him sad or made
him cry you know there's that comic to
move [ __ ] you lady you shouldn't come
out like i don't take it to that level
it's just like
yeah you're right you know i didn't i
didn't think of that i didn't know you
were going to be here tonight what are
the [ __ ] odds you were at that thing
that i was making fun of you know what i
mean but that can happen but what i
think is i i refuse to apologize
to anybody that is upset that they that
they heard a joke at a show they weren't
at
you know especially if somebody film
okay if it's in my special that's
different i decided to like put it out
or whatever
um
but like
you know if it's one of those things
where someone in the crowd films you and
then they put it up it's like get mad at
them and you
because you you saw the subject and you
clicked on it so i mean that's that's
all these other [ __ ] things they have
like they they have videos of just dog
snoring that you could watch
and feel good about your day but you
went out of your way to [ __ ] watch
this thing it's on you well the fact
that it's shown up in their algorithm
means that they're [ __ ] already in
the energy field of all those videos and
that's something i love to do blaming
the victim
well what were you watching if you saw
it yeah
yeah how did it pop up on your no i i am
uh
i'm a big believer and if you are wrong
and you feel you're wrong you apologize
but i'm not
a believer in the mob mentality and i'm
now going to apologize just because it's
not worth it because then all i do is
give that
strength that that's okay to do that and
then some other comics gonna have to
deal with it so
um yeah so like yeah
if you come up to me after a [ __ ]
show i mean i i'll listen to you and
i'll be there and if i agree with what
you're saying i'll be yeah all right
okay
i [ __ ] up i'm sorry yeah yeah it
wasn't a personal thing i'm sorry i'm
sorry you went through that or whatever
and i found you can like actually
they'll be cool with you in the you know
people like anybody like us we want to
be heard so but as far as that that you
know that professional being offended so
you can move whatever cause
because you feel like you can fix
society you know with your ideas i mean
i i don't i don't get into that
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you